quand gérard une fois de plus tu as
tourné avec jean paul belmondo un
dernier film de claude zidi l'animal or
tu as vu le film tu l'a aimée et
l'animal c'est qui c'est la question
qu'on se pose immense et jean-paul
séparé qu'elle winch savoir à quel way
si jean-paul lorsque l'animal animal je
sais pas pourquoi ils ont trouvé ce
titre all eyes on penser peut-être que
c'était commercial ouais alors là on le
voit avec une tenue de saint jean fait
une tare et envoie en tenue de sages on
le voit se battant contre un tigre on le
voit sur les ailes d'un avion mais c'est
un rêve d'enfance à elle a toujours
voulu il rêvait toujours de monter sur
les ailes d'un avion et ses parents
étaient et les filles terrifiés
et alors le soir elle le soir ou le
lendemain il devait tourner la bille on
lui a dit a menacé d'y commander qui
suit atmosphérique que ça marche pas
bien
il ya là toutes les radios le matin on
annonçait qu'il allait monter sur les
ailes d'un avion et ça a été dramatique
pour les parents pendant toute la
journée du tournage quand on a fait
l'avion et les départs à partir nu est
découvert par six caméras mais d'ici là
après on va le refaire
moi je suis monté là haut
alors je suis vite redescendus sains
sont les fous moi je dis qu'il est fou
moi dit qu'il est inconscient
[Musique]
si un combat avec un titre
mais oui mais ça c'est plus dangereux je
vais dire quelque chose
les assureurs ils ont bien voulu de
l'assuré pour l'avion mais on dit pour
le tigre tintin mais surprend il avait
raison ce que le petit grain moment
cuite l'a mordu si le tigre a mordu la
porte
mordue mordu il la porte mais exprès
mais c'est que c'est lui qui l'a énervé
1 il a voulu l'a voulu vraiment s'amuser
avec lui puis l'autre c'est comme des
bêtes
un moment il a vu il a joué il l'a pas
mordu mais formidable en et deux titres
[Musique]
mais deux films ont filmé on a
l'impression que jean paul belmondo est
assez tenté par le danger qu'ils amusent
voulu apporter un sujet avec des 1000
cascades il va sauter d'une planète à
l'autre lit pas le sujet et les cascades
[Musique]